[Música]
desde 1990 la homosexualidad Dejó de ser
un diagnóstico médico para la
Organización Mundial de la Salud lo que
implicó primero reconocer que la
diversidad sexual No es una enfermedad y
por lo tanto que hace parte de nuestras
decisiones como sujetos de Derechos
Humanos sin embargo el tema sigue siendo
objeto de debates existen aún alrededor
del mundo las mal llamadas terapias de
conversión la discriminación es desde
puntos de vista religiosos e incluso la
criminalización de la homosexualidad con
prohibiciones de reafirmación de género
penas de cárcel y hasta ejecuciones
contra esas visiones anti derechos o
cada 17 de mayo se celebra el día
internacional contra la homofobia la
bifobia la interfobia y la transfobia y
Ese es nuestro tema de hoy bienvenidos
al debate
para esta conversación está en el
estudio Alexandra Benítez ella es
investigadora y psicóloga de Derechos
Humanos e incidencia política en la
corporación Caribe afirmativo además de
ser parte del colectivo memoria trans
también se conectan con el debate vía
Skype colet spinetti Núñez quien es
presidenta del colectivo trance del
Uruguay integrante del bloque trance y
disidente de Uruguay y secretaria
general de la red corpora en libertad
también Diane Rodríguez presidenta de la
asociación silueta x y de la federación
nacional lgb temas Ya regreso con
ustedes para las preguntas pero antes
recordarles a nuestros televidentes que
ustedes también hacen parte de este
debate dejen sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
en Twitter en Facebook y en instagram
nos pueden encontrar como arroba franz24
guión bajo es la etiqueta es el numeral
el debate f24 a mí me encuentran en
Twitter Como ángel hago f24
no olviden tampoco que todos los
contenidos de nuestro programa están
disponibles para ustedes en Apple
podcast Spotify deezer y en TuneIn
y se abre este debate las personas
lesbianas gays bisexuales transgénero
cuir e intersexuales las
lgbtiq y más tienen derecho a ser
reconocidas con sus derechos humanos
universales vamos a comenzar con las
preguntas inicio aquí en casa en el
estudio Alexandra gracias
Muy buenas tardes para todas todos y
todas un cordial saludo y gracias por la
invitación extendida aquí al espacio
mire hay mucho tema que abarcar
Alexandra y pues esto también va para
dar a nuestras otras dos invitadas pero
vamos a iniciar con los tratamientos de
afirmación de género esta misma semana
fue prohibida en Florida Estados Unidos
la atención médica para personas
diversas Como por ejemplo los
bloqueadores de la pubertad la terapia
hormonal y esto especialmente para
jóvenes transgénero pero también además
se pusieron obstáculos para los adultos
que quieren acceder a este tipo de
terapias y una de las polémicas en torno
a la diversidad tiene que ver con la
edad porque sí o no los menores de edad
deberían tener acceso
Yo creo que es importante reconocer que
los Derechos Humanos no deben ser
negados para ningún tipo de población no
y en ese sentido reconocer que existen
las infancias y adolescencias con
experiencia de vida trans es entender
que necesitan determinadas garantías y
el reconocimiento de sus derechos para
reafirmar su identidad de género no
no obstante yo creo que sin duda alguna
las personas trans han tenido que
recurrir a miles de intervenciones
artesanales quirúrgicas desde diferentes
lugares clandestinos y que se generen
este tipo de leyes digamos sobre las
reafirmaciones de identidad de género de
infancias y adolescencias trans no va a
detener que las infancias y
adolescencias trans dejen de existir van
a seguir sin duda alguna existiendo pero
sin garantías y sin derechos y eso es lo
que reclamamos a los Estados y a las
organizaciones y a las entidades
internacionales y es entender que las
vidas trans no pueden ser en debate sino
se garantizar sus derechos
independientemente del lugar que habiten
y el ciclo
o la etapa intergeneracional que estén
habitando en este momento de su vida
pregunta para usted lo que estamos
hablando aquí con Alexandra en el
estudio tiene que ver con una
interpretación que se aleja del
binarismo y que reconoce que existen
infancias trans así como existen
ciudadanos y ciudadanas trans en todo el
mundo
cómo deberíamos reinterpretar estas
infancias trans contra el argumento por
ejemplo que existe de que no han todavía
los niños decidido o no tienen criterio
todavía para decidir Cómo quieren vivir
su sexualidad cómo lo ve usted
primero Muchísimas gracias por invitarme
a este espacio
un saludo inmenso a las demás invitadas
y a toda la teleaudiencia en este
sentido tenemos que diferenciar dos
cosas Una es la identidad de género de
las personas y otra es la orientación
sexual de las personas se tiende a
confundir muchas veces que la
orientación sexual determina la
identidad de género y eso no es así son
dos caminos independientes por otro lado
decir que bueno los estudios académicos
y científicos y nuestra propia
experiencia de vida demuestran que la
identidad de género
se empieza a manifestar alrededor de los
tres años
[Música]
y esto no es algo impuesto ni algo que
se elija en Uruguay nosotros tenemos la
ley integral para personas trans permite
a niños menores de edad con el permiso
de sus padres de sus progenitores
cambiarse género y nombre de hecho
tenemos casos de de estos dentro de mi
organización está la familia y la primer
niña trans que cambió nombre de género
en el Uruguay en este sentido lo que sí
hay en
digamos en en América y especialmente en
Latinoamérica es una ola de
adultoscentrismo donde las niñeces
empiezan a perder el lugar de ser sujeto
sujetas de derecho
las niñeces empiezan a considerarse que
no tienen derechos que no tienen
voluntad que no tienen poder de decisión
y por lo tanto hay como
un aumento del poder de de la adultez y
en especial de los estados que imponen
estas leyes no olvidemos que por ejemplo
en Guatemala Hay un proyecto de ley
también que este prohíbe las infancias
transcondenas las infancias trans y así
en una gran cantidad de países tenemos
países como Paraguay donde no hay
ninguna ley de reconocimiento y menos
para la infancia países como Perú
donde no existe el reconocimiento
entonces
invisibilizar las infancias es
invisibilizar a las personas y no
permitirle ser sujeta sujetos de derecho
con toda
la consecuencia
psicoemocional que eso trae pensemos en
la altísima el altísimo número de
intentos de suicidios y de suicidios
dentro de la comunidad trans yo creo que
las personas trans tenemos mínimos tres
intentos de suicidio en nuestras vidas y
eso tiene que ver con la represión a las
personas trans en su infancia Pues bien
Ahora Quisiera darle la palabra a Diana
Un saludo para ustedes dayane y quisiera
que hiciéramos un poco de pedagogía pues
para efectos de esta conversación No
porque no es lo mismo ser una persona
transexual que una persona transgénero y
esas son dos líneas que es bueno también
trazar para entender que no
necesariamente la autopercepción de una
persona tiene que ver con modificaciones
a su cuerpo o a su biología
Hola Sí muchas gracias por la invitación
en efecto Pero quizás eso es hilar
demasiado sobre todo para aquellas
personas que no entienden claramente
acerca de justamente de las distinciones
solo básicas de la identidad de género y
la orientación sexual que justamente
hablaba con él ahora sí vamos a tratar
de cómo es de perfilar o o Buscar lo más
mínimo dentro de la población trans eso
obviamente entraría en una discusión muy
compleja pero en todo caso si deseamos
abordar justamente la misma con el
conocimiento claro y por supuesto los
estándares sobre todo dentro de la
comunidad trans que se habla estaríamos
entendiendo que las personas
transgéneros serían aquellas que
transgreden el género en su vida
cotidiana y que a partir de aquello de
este tránsito de esta experiencia de
vida trans no tiene que ver por lo que
se por lo menos en Ecuador en algunos
otros países también lo contemplan así
con intervenciones quirúrgicas u
hormonales en el caso de que alguna
persona tenga
alguna intervención quirúrgica o
hormonal entonces estaríamos hablando de
una persona ya transexual y No
necesariamente haya pasado por un
proceso de reasignación sexual porque
anteriormente cuando no estaban muy
difundidos o muy entendidos los términos
entendía que una persona transexual era
aquella Que ya había concluido Por
decirlo así si lo vemos de una forma
lineal con su proceso de transición y
eso tenía que ver con la intervención
incluso hasta quirúrgica de sus
genitales y que si no lo había concluido
Entonces no se la consideraba como una
persona transexual pero a lo largo del
tiempo hay un sinnúmero de debates
alrededor de aquello y esto de aquí sea
justamente entendido o por lo menos así
se lo estudia en Ecuador que aquellas
personas que hacen estas intervenciones
quirúrgicas y hormonales ya son
consideradas personas transexuales Pero
dentro de este Marco también es
importante entender que estas
discusiones más bien tienen que ver con
el aspecto mucho más
íntimo Por decirlo de una u otra manera
del movimiento trans que No
necesariamente tiene ser entendido por
la población en general la población en
general tiene que entender que las
identidades trans las experiencias de
vida de tránsito en el mismo derecho que
cualquier otra persona y que
Lamentablemente como se lo acaba de
mencionar en algunos países y ahora que
se lo ve terriblemente en Estados Unidos
con estas limitaciones en las que
justamente tiene que ver con el
desarrollo de las experiencias de vida
trans lo único que hacen es hacer creer
que hay algo que curar que tenemos que
pasar por procesos psicoterapéuticos o
terapéuticos o psiquiátricos o
religiosos o incluso hasta torturas aquí
en Ecuador justamente no hace menos de
unas dos semanas se han denunciado casos
que han recluido a personas de la
diversidad desde el centro psicotrans de
la asociación
de Quito hemos venido denunciando esto
estas clínicas de tortura porque son
torturas o de conversión y mal llamadas
de des homosexualización o de
destransexualización que existen en
Ecuador y a lo largo de varios países
dentro latinoamérica Lamentablemente lo
único que ofrecen es algo que no se
puede eh
convertir más bien se convierte en un
proceso de tortura y dentro de aquello
incluso aquí en Ecuador se encuentra
reconocido no integralmente como lo
acabo de mencionar pero sí en el código
orgánico integral penal a partir
justamente de el ámbito de tortura según
el artículo 68 no recuerdo en el que se
menciona justamente que cualquier
persona que intente cambiar o modificar
la identidad de género o la orientación
sexual de una persona
Lamentablemente puede incluir en una
tortura Y eso obviamente es penalizado
entre ocho a doce años dependiendo de la
agravante Bueno hay otro tema y es
separar digamos los dogmático de lo
penal y de los Derechos Humanos basados
también pues en estándares
internacionales sobre eso quisiera
conversar con usted Alexandra ya que
nuestra otra invitada trae a colación
las mal llamadas terapias de conversión
que suceden alrededor del mundo Pese a
que han sido declaradas violatorias de
los Derechos Humanos terapia de
conversión es tortura porque bajo ese
mismo argumento Alexandra se han
realizado otras prácticas culturales
Como por ejemplo la mutilación genital
femenina en un contexto en el que creen
las familias que eso es lo mejor para
sus hijas hijos e hijas aquí pues hay un
proceso que más que de rechazo y usted
me va a corregir de educación
Sí yo Considero que hablar de las mal
llamadas terapias de conversión que al
final del día termina siendo esfuerzos
por eliminar la orientación sexual
identidad o expresión de género o
modificarlas sin duda alguna pone un
debate dentro de la mesa un debate que
no debe ser puesto sin duda alguna y que
implica reconocer por ejemplo es un
ejercicio que ha venido realizando out
junto a la revista volcánicas y la
corporación Caribe afirmativo en el que
recoge alrededor de 2.700 testimonios de
personas lgbti que fueron Víctimas de
terapias de conversión no
hablamos de un número sin duda alguna
grande no y arroja un poco como esta
investigación como que una de cada
cuatro personas que vive o es víctima de
una terapia de conversión
puede suicidarse no yo creo que implica
reconocer que los derechos sexuales y
reproductivos Deben estar garantizados
para cualquier persona
independientemente de su orientación
sexual una cantidad o expresión de
género y que en ese sentido en Colombia
ya existen proyectos de ley que buscan
prohibir las terapias de conversión en
el territorio nacional también Creo que
implica reconocer que las terapias de
conversión se han dado desde diferentes
lugares y escenarios por ejemplo es
entender que desde los sectores étnicos
y raizales las terapias de conversión
ocupan un lugar diferente no porque los
resguardos indígenas son diferentes los
procedimientos pero finalmente buscan
erradicar la orientación o identidad de
género de la persona y por ejemplo
yéndonos al contexto o al en el marco
del conflicto armado en Colombia lo que
sucedió en el marco de la guerra fuera
en terapias de conversión no hechos
victimizantes alrededor de el
reclutamiento forzado
el desplazamiento las amenazas que
buscaban también modificar o eliminar la
diversidad de sus territorios a partir
de la presencia de grupos armados
y legales dentro del territorio Yo creo
que implica reconocer más que el debate
implica reconocer las realidades que
viven personas lgbti que son Víctimas de
terapias de conversión y que sin duda
alguna
organizaciones y entidades se lucran a
partir del dolor y el sufrimiento humano
Porque el estudio también habla de que
estas terapias de conversión pueden
tener un costo de entre 500.000 a 5
millones de pesos entonces colombianos
colombianos Exacto Entonces implica que
personas organizaciones y grupos que no
se piensan la diversidad sexual como una
agenda política y de Derechos Humanos se
lucren por medio del sufrimiento y el
dolor de un sector que históricamente ha
sido oprimido es interesante Alexandra
que usted está citando una reportaje
periodístico que se hizo digamos a nivel
Colombia y que también toca las aristas
de la situación latinoamericana y en
aras creo que de ampliar esta discusión
la obligación en France 24 y desde sus
organizaciones de promover que haya un
debate que se mueva hacia los
científicos no hacia la investigación
ahí hay un libro bien interesante que se
llama la invención de los sexos de una
doctora en estudios de género Argentina
llamada lucichia y esto para referencia
de nuestros televidentes es interesante
entender y ella lo hace muy bien
explicar cómo venimos de una historia
binaria no Y cómo Ese binarismo es más
una imposición social que una realidad
natural en las personas y con esto pues
quisiera hablar ahora nuevamente con
College porque lo plantea luciche en su
libro Si todos estuviéramos en una isla
en la que no tenemos un lenguaje
desarrollado todavía pero sí tenemos una
genitalidad y una corporalidad pues No
necesariamente nos identificaríamos
todos inmediatamente como hombre y mujer
sino que la misma biología nos elige
para para ser diversos en nuestra
naturaleza usted de qué opina sobre
sobre esta clasificación binaria contra
la que todavía organizaciones como la
suya luchan tan fuertemente
bueno a ver esta clasificación binaria
es una clasificación que proviene de
del colonialismo y además de la mano de
la religión no es decir con aquel
discurso de las religiones de Eva la que
condena el mundo ha sido un argumento
para condenar y a las mujeres por
ejemplo a ver este binarismo Nosotros
siempre hablamos de que son
es el sexo impuesto al nacer tengo una
amiga chilena
trans que siempre dice y le robo la
frase el patriarcado me traicionó porque
el patriarcado no me preguntó a mí
qué género era yo sino que el
patriarcado lo que hizo fue mirar mi
genitalidad e imponerme un
verdad Y esta imposición de los sexos
lleva a que después todo en nuestros
estados se distribuya alrededor de ese
sexo impuesto al nacer los baños las
escuelas los centros de salud los
servicios de salud las cárceles todo se
se organiza alrededor de este binarismo
que le ha dicho mucho mal Perdón que le
que le ha hecho mucho mal a la sociedad
Perdóneme que le termine la frase pero
es que quiero darle más espacio también
a las otras invitadas y solo agregarle
que claro esta esta agresividad o esta
esta actitud pasivo agresiva que se ven
cosas tan sencillas como las niñas
visten Rosa y los niños visten azul No
desde ahí podemos empezar a hacer
nuestra evaluación Quisiera pasar a otro
tema para que no se nos queden por fuera
todas las los asuntos que hay que
abarcar con Diane Y es que incluso en
los grupos de defensa de derechos hay
discordancias entonces hay
discriminación también en esos nichos o
que son considerados de lucha de
derechos me gustaría que habláramos un
poco de lo que es el terfismo versus los
feminismos incluyentes y y pues que
continuemos en en aras de esta discusión
de ser hombre o mujer o un
autodeterminación Más allá de la
biología
sí Bueno hay que reconocer que en
nuestros países Lamentablemente la
cuestión que tiene que ver con el
feminismo Todavía está en crecimiento y
me refiero que hay algunos movimientos
que excluyen a las mujeres trans a
partir justamente de una Concepción
biológica como también lo mencionaba
hace un momento las compañeras Entonces
en ese sentido no es como en otros
países donde de repente el feminismo
tiene Claro que es una un proceso de
equidad de inclusión que tiene que ver
justamente con la participación de todos
los actores de la sociedad en general y
que no necesariamente tiene que ver con
la parte biológica o incluso el género y
en Ecuador por ejemplo Nosotros hemos
tenido experiencias sobre todo las
personas trans me acuerdo en el año 2013
en el no me acuerdo Creo que era el
treceavo encuentro de latinoamericano de
mujeres que se desarrolló en Perú fuimos
un grupo de personas trans y en ese
momento en cambio estas feministas entre
comillas que yo diría que son justamente
no permitían Ingresar a hombres trans
pero sí a mujeres trans Entonces nos
topábamos con otra realidad por ejemplo
en Ecuador que sí se permitía la
participación de hombres trans porque
habían nacido biológicamente mujeres en
cambio las mujeres trans no se la dejaba
participar porque había nacido
biológicamente varones Los varones ya
sean cis o incluso
homosexuales sin importar su orientación
sexual tampoco les permitían participar
y mucho menos a los heterosexuales
entonces unas discusiones alrededor
justamente dentro del movimiento
feminista vuelvo a repetir radical no
todo el movimiento feminista es así pero
en algunos se mantiene justamente esta
radicalización de la exclusión de las
personas a partir de sus estructuras
fisiológicas o comportamentales de
género en la vida y eso Lamentablemente
lo único que hace por supuesto es
reducir los espectros de lucha y sobre
todo de inclusión a nivel general y no
solamente en los países sino a nivel
regional Cuando somos testigos
justamente este tipo de situaciones aquí
en Ecuador ha habido mucho ataque de
hecho yo hace mucho tiempo dejé de
participar en el movimiento feminista
directamente por justamente este tipo de
cuestiones en las que se veía
en contra justamente de las poblaciones
trans en donde hay un crecimiento a
nivel regional y yo diría justamente a
nivel mundial con el terfismo
Bueno vamos a pasar al siguiente tema ya
que corre tan rápido el reloj Alexandra
lenguaje incluyente si no y por qué
creo que el lenguaje incluyente es
necesario no surge mucho este discurso
del lenguaje incluyente realmente es
garantizar brailes garantizar
lengua de señas o intérpretes en lengua
de señas pero yo creo que es importante
entender que cada sector tiene como sus
formas de reclamar derechos no yo creo
que el lenguaje Es una herramienta muy
poderosa que tenemos para el
reconocimiento de las identidades y las
orientaciones sexuales diversas y sin
duda alguna creo que el lenguaje
incluyente reconoce también otros
lugares que no se enuncian Desde el
binarismo no hay personas no binarias
dentro del espectro no binario que no
logran reconocerse a partir de este
sistema que impone solo dos
posibilidades de habitar la masculinidad
O la feminidad y que sin duda alguna
También tienen que ser reconocidas
jurídicamente en Colombia por ejemplo
hay un avance muy gigante y es el
reconocimiento de las identidades no
binarias dentro del sistema ju
colombiano Y eso impone unos retos para
el Sistema Nacional estadístico y para
el dane también como herramienta
estadística entonces creo que sin duda
alguna Debemos hablar del lenguaje de
inclusión pero también Debemos hablar de
acciones afirmativas que reconozcan esos
lugares que no habitan el binarismo
masculino o femenino claro las personas
que a veces se identifican con la x y
sobre eso también nos puede hablar mucho
con él porque Argentina también ha sido
pionera en esa materia y sigamos
hablando alrededor de la inclusión
versus la criminalización 67 países del
Mundo todavía criminalizan la diversidad
sexual ponen castigos que van desde
penas de cárcel sanciones hasta incluso
ejecuciones por mantener relaciones que
no se clasifican dentro de lo binario
cómo vamos en el mundo en términos de
inclusión porque ustedes tres hacen
parte de organizaciones que tienen una
lucha incansable y que viene de décadas
de cientos de años atrás
Pues cómo vamos
bueno a ver tenemos el caso ahora de
uganda que es el más reciente de la
criminalización pero también tenemos
países en nuestra latinoamérica y el
Caribe que criminalizan
la homosexualidad y más aún la identidad
de género trans en este sentido si bien
habemos países que hemos avanzado en el
reconocimiento de derechos pero como
siempre digo en esa conciencia
de lucha colectiva no nos podemos quedar
con que nuestro país ha avanzado sino
que tenemos que también
fortalecer nuestras redes para que otros
países también puedan avanzar Acá hay
una cosa que no se entiende y es que las
personas de la comunidad lgbtqimas y en
especial las personas trans somos
personas y somos seres humanos y somos
seres humanos debemos gozar de todos los
derechos
También tenemos que pensar en que estos
países que no tienen que criminalizan
también hay países que no criminalizan
pero que sí la sociedad criminaliza yo
personalmente trabajo con personas trans
privadas de libertad
tanto en Uruguay como en Latinoamérica
El Caribe
Integra una red y hay una
criminalización social también de la
comunidad trans la comunidad trans la
que está fuera la que debe ser dejada
afuera la que debe ser encerrada la que
es como el objeto de todos los males Y
entonces hay una criminalización social
por eso tenemos un tal alto índice de
asesinatos por odio en Latinoamérica y
el Caribe en ese sentido vuelvo a
repetir
debemos de trabajar en conjunto con
redes muy fuertes para que todos los
países
logre
discriminalizar La orientación sexual y
la identidad de género y reconocer
derechos de la comunidad lgbtqimas pues
Bien muchísimas gracias a nuestras tres
invitadas por las aclaraciones que están
realizando Yo quisiera que ya pasáramos
a una ronda de conclusiones y les lanzo
a las tres la misma pregunta ya hemos
hablado de todo lo malo de todo lo que
está erróneo según la postura de
derechos que ustedes defienden pero
ahora quisiera que cerráramos este
programa hablando de esos pequeños
eventos o grandes eventos que a ustedes
les dan esperanza en un mundo más
incluyente y comienzo con Alexandra
yo solo Quisiera dejar un mensaje hoy
nos faltan 145 personas lgbti en el país
asesinadas por la violencia por el
prejuicio y en muchos países de
latinoamérica no existen por ejemplo
garantías para el ejercicio de las
personas trans yo Considero que
es necesario seguir reafirmando el
compromiso de los estados con las
agendas de diversidad sexual y de género
y entender que no es un tema de decir o
no brindarle derechos es que las
personas lgbti somos sujetas de derechos
Y eso implica que el estado garantice
dentro de sus agendas políticas
el acceso a diversos procedimientos
dañan sus conclusiones sobre nuestros
avances como sociedad
Bueno yo Considero que
afortunadamente a pesar de todas las
vicisitudes que se ven en la región los
asesinatos
Quizás es momento también de que la
sociedad en general reflexione y yo
siempre comparo el movimiento lgbt con
lo que ha sucedido con el movimiento
afro ha seguido procesos justamente de
inclusión poco a poco a través de las
luchas de actores que se han
identificado a lo largo del tiempo y en
diferentes contextos y yo creo que
sucede lo mismo con nuestras poblaciones
O sea si comparamos hacemos una analogía
de los afrodescendientes por ejemplo las
iglesias blancas las universidades
blancas y todos esos espacios en donde
se excluía a los afros lo mismo ha
pasado con nosotros el tema del
matrimonio el tema de la adopción el
tema de la participación en política de
las personas lgbt y sobre todo las
personas trans a pesar de todas estas
problemáticas poco a poco hemos ido
avanzando y con esto no quiero decir que
este quizás en algunos países hemos
avanzado de forma legal pero a nivel
estructural Lamentablemente hace falta
ese cambio no Y eso tiene con una
comprensión del comportamiento de la
sociedad en general y que yo esperaría
que ojalá que con el pasar de los años
tal como ha pasado con el movimiento
afrodescendiente y con esto no estoy
diciendo que no sufre discriminación y
no hay racismo porque sí lo hay poco a
poco esto también vaya
eliminándose dentro de nuestras
poblaciones y cada vez seamos partícipes
mucho más dentro de la sociedad en
general entonces eso que nos vean como
seres humanos Porque todos somos seres
humanos principalmente y aquellos
justamente nos hace acreedores de la
participación social de la vida y de
todas las cuestiones que tiene que ver
alrededor de la sociedad en general
y colette
bien Yo estaba escuchando a las
compañeras y y venía pensando cuánto
Cuánta agua ha pasado bajo el puente
como se dice en Uruguay Cuántas luchas
Cuántas compañeras han puesto sus
cuerpos en la calle para que hoy por
ejemplo estemos en este espacio hablando
de la comunidad trans
Esto hace
diez veinte años atrás
ni se pensaba y Hoy estamos en un
espacio televisivo internacional
tres personas trans hablando sobre la
problemática trans ahí Creo que hay un
gran avance y esto tiene que ver con las
luchas que la sociedad civil que la
comunidad trans en general que en la
mayoría de los países ha sido iniciada
por mujeres trans y por suerte después
aparecieron los el trance hoy están
apareciendo las personas no binarias
para reforzar esta lucha esas luchas han
dado estos resultados y más allá de los
reconocimientos legales de derecho yo
Considero que hoy la lucha es cultural
hoy tenemos que cambiar tenemos que
buscar estrategias para cambiar la
matriz cultural de nuestra sociedades si
la matriz cultural cambia
las las la el reconocimiento legal
siquiera va a ser necesario porque vamos
a vivir en una sociedad mucho más
igualitaria
bueno es que los activismos comienzan
desde la calle Muchísimas gracias a
nuestras tres invitadas y para nuestros
televidentes la invitación es a
continuar informándose y a continuar con
una vigencia para la discusión que al
final es lo que más le aporta a la
diversidad estuvieron con nosotros
Alexandra Benítez investigadora y
psicóloga de derechos humanos de
incidencia política y representante de
Caribe afirmativo gracias a usted
Alexandra gracias por la invitación
Gracias también ampliamente aculet
spinetti Núñez presidenta del colectivo
trance del Uruguay integrante del bloque
trance y disidente de Uruguay y
secretaría de la red corpora en diversas
Muchísimas gracias a ustedes gracias a
las compañeras y gracias a quienes nos
están viendo porque eso es más que
importante y Dayana también una calurosa
despedida para ustedes presidenta de la
asociación silueta x y de la federación
nacional lgbt+
Muchas gracias también por la invitación
y por supuesto a las compañeras y
aquellas personas que nos están viendo y
creen justamente en nuestras poblaciones
gracias
pues ha sido un placer estar con ustedes
en un nuevo debate la producción general
del programa estuvo a cargo de Andrés
doncelele y a cargo de la producción de
nuestras invitadas Tania Herrera sigan
con nosotros en France 24 ya volvemos
con más
[Música]